here we go!
Build something cool, blow something up or simply
blow people's minds! If you're passionate about making things
and looking for new projects to try, I know exactly how you feel!
hey guys I'm grant thompson the king of
random and make weekly videos dedicated
to exploring life through all kinds of
life hacks experiments in random weekend
projects
subscribe to my channel and you learn
how to turn garden potatoes into an
incredible magical mud-filled
build laser-assisted drill guns and make
mountains and mountains of delicious
gummy candies at home. We'll repurpose
everyday items to build a fully
functional rockets from scratch and
expose the secrets for making your
favorite soda drinks and water bottles
freeze instantly on command
subscribe now and you'll see how to
build covert compartments for hiding
important things around your house and
learn my method for crafting a simple
backyard Forge to melt pop cans and turn
them into anything you want
you've got busy hands and so do i so
click Subscribe and let's start building
something together